nukes and movies cool zombie apocalypse
awesome pathogens scariest [ __ ] ever
contagion
alright now as some of you may know I've
been looking forward to this movie for a
while I love these kind of movies
specifically outbreak I was a big fan of
outbreak back in the day I loved the
hell out of that movie so now I felt
like this is going to be outbreak 2011
so how did it hold up well here it is
now I might compare this movie to the
movie outbreak a few times but in all
fairness you know viruses people dying
outbreak contagion if you don't know
what it's about contagion has an
all-star cast about a virus that's just
wiping out mankind and no one really
knows where this thing came from it was
like the plague back in the day or
Bieber fever two years ago it just
sprung onto the scene just started doing
damage now we got to deal with it but
this virus wasn't messing around I mean
that was really cool to see this thing
kills you in like a day you get it you
feel a little ill by that night you're
dead so it really kind of freaks you out
you're like uh maybe I should wash my
hands more often no but I liked about
this movie where the performances the
performances were solid and it really
focuses on Matt Damon usually movies
like this the movie takes place in like
the span of seven days it was like one
of those ooh the virus is gonna break
out in seven days we deal with it fix it
life goes on this movie takes place in
the span of months so it all just
happens man I mean the virus comes out
people start dying people start getting
scared people start looting people start
killing people are more freaked out it
really shows what would happen in a
situation like this I mean outbreak was
like oh it's in the town or we can't let
it escape the town let's not let it
escape the town contagion is what
happens when the virus escapes the town
yeah we're all screwed but in that the
movie spans months and is condensed into
a two-hour movie it feels like it was
filmed to be a four hour movie and then
it was like edited down to two hours so
it feels like things are missing in the
movie like some of the characters are
useless Marion Cotillard or kotti
however you say her last name I hate
someone else I hate I hate him in any
case she's in the movie and then at a
point you don't see her for like an hour
easily an hour at least an hour and then
later on it shows her again you're like
I forgot that chick was even in this
movie that's right and there's scene
where she's like oh holy crap I need to
get this town I need to get there right
now and she goes she's running and she's
hauling ass and then it changes to the
next scene that she's not in and then
you never see her again in the movie
ever it's the last time you see her what
happened to her did she did she get to
the town did she get into a car wreck
did they edit it out did she find Jimmy
Hoffa she's just gone now I
so in that movie kind of felt a little
disjointed it's a really serious movie -
the funniest part was when it's all
talking about how people touch their
face like 2,000 times a day and they're
shaking hands with people and spreading
germs and it shows it concentrates on
someone like putting down a glass and
someone else picking up the glass and
you're like ah you just transferred a
virus and I'm sitting there I really was
this really happened I'm sitting in the
auditorium opening my candy wrapper with
my teeth while it's explaining this all
like yeah yes Fred and viruses you guys
shouldn't do that if you look pretty
careless yeah there we go don't be dumb
wash your hands that was pretty funny
rest of the movie is dead serious I like
to fear it like seeing people lewd I
like seeing Matt Damon I kind of adapt
to the situation he goes from normal
family guy to the guys surviving in the
apocalypse in the span of 107 days this
takes place but then the movie just cuts
off it just ends like outbreak to
compare it the movie comes to a head and
it's just this intense situation you're
just biting your nails you know you
shouldn't bite your nails because now
you know there are germs under your
nails and you're gonna spread African
Motaba to everything but you're biting
your nails it's really intense
this movie went on and then it ended and
credits and that was that so if you like
these virus movies you're gonna enjoy
this movie but you're not gonna like the
end you're gonna feel like it was a bit
choppy I will say it's a good time no
alcohol required being a very realistic
and scary time in which you're going to
be convinced that you're gonna catch a
virus going home and die the next day I
wanted to like it more than I did but I
still did enjoy it so virus movie virus
scenario outbreak contagion type movie
what's your favorite comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you